here we go this is going to be episode
number seven of the beginner to master
speedrun uh hopefully you know the drill
by now but in this series I started at a
400 ELO and I'm trying to work my way up
as high as possible hopefully share a
lot of lessons along the way um I'm
hoping that today I'll be able to break
700 currently at
695 and as I get higher in Elo my
opponents will be getting stronger so
gradually we'll see some higher level
Concepts
and uh let's waste no more time let's
hop into the first
game okay playing
fuat I'm white we'll start with
E4 and let's see what my opponent would
like to do uh D6 this is a Pierz defense
um not the most common opening I don't
think I've encountered the Pierz in any
game so far in the speedrun but it's
very playable very solid black is now
attacking the pawn on E4 and the reason
why black started with D6 is now I can't
really effectively play E5 because after
takes takes black could trade queens and
take away my casting rights um so the
most solid move here is Knight C3 very
simply developing defending controlling
the center and now C6 so I think this is
called the check Pierz if I'm not
mistaken uh it is a way to play for
black I'm just going to focus on normal
development
uh this is kind of the quintessential
setup to to play in the first four moves
um but now black is being very
aggressive very sneaky moving the queen
to pin my knight so black is actually
threatening to take the pawn on e4 next
move and there's a couple ways to deal
with this uh there's Bishop D3 or Bishop
2D2 I'm going to play Bishop
D3 simply because I want a castle next
move
even though Bishop D2 would align with
the
queen um I think the bishop is going to
be better placed on G5 F4
E3 and now black did waste time moving
the queen a couple
times but uh E5 this is perfectly fine
move uh I can't win a pawn cuz even
though I have two attackers there are
two Defenders with the queen and the
pawn so now it's a question what to do
with this tension
I mean I could leave my Pawn here and if
takes I take back with the Knight I
could
take on E5 but then after it takes it
does open up the bishop for
black and then pushing is another option
but um not super fond of
that I think I just want to complete
development Bishop
G5 CU there's some idea of taking to
give black double pawns and meanwhile
yeah the center is very well defended I
have all the minor pieces
developed and a common theme that we've
seen with a lot of these games um
throughout the series is my opponent
being a little bit slow to complete
development especially of their minor
pieces early in the game um in this case
it might be hard to punish like right
away just because black is so solid so
I'm going to keep improving Queen D2
officially connecting the Rooks
and yeah black
hassles and again if I take then take
don't think it'll really accomplishes
much um moves like Rook D1 or Rook E1 I
think are are very natural just get the
Rooks more
centralized there is a move here that
I'm inclined to play and and sometimes a
good thought process in positions like
this where it's still kind of late
opening early middle game is to ask ask
herself what does the opponent want to
do and of course black wants to complete
development of the queen side I think
one move that black would like to play
is Bishop to G4 so I'm going to play a a
prophylactic move like simply preventing
Bishop G4 with Pawn
H3 and even though this is sometimes not
the most useful I think it's it's a
little bit annoying now for black to not
be able to bring the bishop here and if
Bishop to E6 and maybe maybe at some
point I can get in
D5 although Bishop E6 D5 uh there are a
few too many black things covering the
square
so yeah I think now I'd rather just put
the Rook on
D1 and yeah I didn't want the the bishop
to be pinning my knight to The Rook in
uh in cases where I didn't play
H3 so we see Knight D7 so black has now
developed all of their minor
pieces
and yeah this is interesting because the
bishop can no longer
retreat and I do want to calculate this
move D5 because it is pretty forcing
this Knight in some in some sense is
pinned to the
bishop so if if I imagine Pawn
D5 black would take with a pawn I would
take back
and then the bishop or Knight can
take if the Knight takes I would take
black would take and in the very end I
win the bishop there's also Bishop H7 in
the very end to have the discovered
attack against
D5 so let's look at this one more time
D5 take
take we just saw I was just calculating
Knight takes so if Bishop takes it is a
little bit different
let's imagine Bishop take Knight take
Knight
take and I don't have Bishop takes E7
because the Knight can recapture but in
that line I do have Bishop takes
H7 and this might be one of the most
like complex lines I've calculated
throughout the
series I'm pretty
sure it's not bad for white I'm not sure
how good it is but at the very least
we'll be Trading
and black is going to have to be very
careful not to like lose a piece in
these
variations so yeah even though there's
two Defenders and three attackers I'm
kind of relying on the fact that I'm
going to have pressure with the defile
some eventual tactic with Bishop takes
H7 or the eventual like Bishop takes
E7 we do see Bishop takes
D5
yeah I think this is the best approach
for black and now I'm
debating does it matter if I take on H7
first probably want to take
on D5
first and I did just lose a pawn in on
all these trades but the whole point is
I'm going to win it back with Bishop
takes H7 and again if I take on E7
Knight takes back and I'm not winning
anything there so let's take on
H7 yeah that was basically a very fancy
trade now I'll take the
Knight but the position has transformed
a ton I
mean so many pieces have been traded off
and black going haywire with the king
king
G6 uh I was just expecting King G8 but
was King being
adventurous I could take on
D6 and then take take I lose a knight I
win the Knight back it's not a bad
option the other idea is to try and like
just Checkmate the king somehow move
maybe like
F4 but F4 does allow the queen
trade maybe
H4 yeah I was hoping to like get in F4
but after Queen C5 then I'm in check we
would trade
Queens I'm going to play
H4 Queen digs D6 was also I think
completely fine in that
position um but because of the time
situation I'd rather try and win the
game quicker there's also a principle
when the opponent's king is less safe
you want to keep Queens on the
board uh so now I move like Queen
D3 or queen
E4 I'm going to play Queen D3
check it is retreating but in the event
of King H6 I'm already
mating probably also with King H5 Queen
H7 so we see
F5 and now that's I should note I do
have the fork if I want
it there's also Queen G3 I feel like I'm
spoiled for Choice here but I do have to
move a bit quicker I'm going to go for
the fork just win
material um Queen and Rook are now
attacked and D6 is also probably going
to be falling at some
point not to mention I do have ideas of
Queen G3 which might even be stronger
than taking the
Rook yeah because if the king moves this
way I'm
meaning King moves this way
I think my knight is more powerful than
the Rook even though I can take and win
material I'd rather start by taking the
pawn because the Knight is such a good
attacking piece and I am threatening
Queen takes G7 now still threatening The
Rook I think black is going to have
to defend like Rook G is probably the
best try
here
okay we see King
E8 again I could take the Rook but I'd
really like to keep my knight on the
board there's Queen G6 there's Queen
takes
G7 there's Knight takes
G7 little bit spoiled for
Choice I'm going to play Knight takes
G7 winning the pawn with
check and a move like Rook D1 looks
really
nice
simply doubling
up
and yeah maybe I had something better
there but I'm getting all my pieces
involved Black's not giving
up okay so now I mean I could take the
Knight I could take the rook and then
take the
pawn at this point it's probably just a
matter of
simplifying
I think I'm inclined to take the Knight
and after Queen
takes I could start with Queen takes
E5 and then just take the
Queen the next move like the Queen's
still hanging the king's attacked if
Queen E6 I'll play Knight takes
E6 I will say this is probably the
highest level game I've played so far
like it's required a lot of uh a lot of
calculations in various moments
um but now it's a matter of clean up
clean up time um taking the pawn queen
D6
coming yeah let's push the
pawn important to note I did make Luft
uh if my Pawn res on H2 black would be
mating but that's not the
case and the most efficient way here is
to make another
queen uh
or yeah this position is actually checkm
in two Let's uh let's go for Queen D6
and then Knight E7 will be
Checkmate okay tried to be efficient
there uh very interesting
game I think my opponent was playing
more of a system based opening yeah this
is a the cze
Pierz I think maybe more often black
will play Queen C7 or Knight D7 right
away to prepare E5 so black lost a
little bit of time in the opening but
then things got very spicy I played this
move
D5 but um sometimes when your pieces are
like developed and on good squares like
this then it should be your goal to open
the position just because many times the
tactics will favor the side with the
batter Place pieces and we saw how the
position transformed even though I
didn't win any material right away my
opponent got a little bit feisty with
the king I guess I was winning the pawn
though in in this
variation I think in this position it's
not easy for black to find a move to
keep this defended like maybe Knight F6
maybe Pawn F6 but wasn't
pretty and then yeah then it was a
matter of
attacking I imagine maybe there is a a
better way to win maybe a force mate but
that was a fun game uh let's move on to
another one I've officially broken
700 so we'll do a new 10-minute
game playing chess ninja
24 and I'm going to stick with the
classical opening repertoire Kings Pawn
opening and we have a
Spanish the Spanish opening I like to
play the
most common variation which is Pawn
A6 this gives white the chance to go
into the exchange
variation now there is a small trap here
white takes a pawn which we do see um
it's not supposed to be that great for
white even though I'm not going to be
winning material I'm going to be winning
back the pawn with this move Queen
D4 I think I may have shown this in like
one of the previous
episodes uh it's very good to know if
you play the Kings Pawn opening so
inevitably you'll encounter the Roy
Lopez or the
Spanish and um I don't think I've ever
seen this move Queen H5 before
before very clever though defending the
Knight and threatening
F7 now I don't have to defend F7 right
away because I can regain the pawn and
check the
king I think I'd like to do
that my opponent going straight for the
kill white has three legal moves here
King F1 King D1 and queen E2 to I think
King D1 is the most interesting cuz it
sets up rook
E1 and then I would have to be very
careful in that case we see Queen
E2 um and
now yeah I don't think I want to take on
G2 because then I'm subjecting myself to
some
discoveries so I think it's simplest
here just to trade
queens and we're entering a position
where it's equal
material I might as well develop and
attack the
Knight but even though it is equal
material there's a few
imbalances and one of the imbalances
that's in my favor is I have the two
Bishops against bishop and
Knight and in a relatively open position
like this uh usually the two Bishops are
just a bit more
valuable we'll start with Bishop
F5 so with both developing Bishop moves
I'm attacking something that's
undefended this case attacking
C2 and at some point I would like to
Castle but my king is tied down to
defending
F7 so if we see a move like C3
here and there's not too many ways for
white to defend the pawn or King
D2 um I was thinking I would play
F6 just to get the Knight away and then
look to Castle I could also take like
take take and castle with check is nice
at least nice
looking but I think I'd rather keep this
bishop or later like I don't want to
Trail it off so soon and White's going
to have to spend time now moving the
Knight I imagine we'll see maybe Knight
F3 maybe Knight C4
okay so white yeah white might be able
to trade this bishop off
anyway I was initially thinking Bishop
F4
check I'm not sure how much I'm
achieving
there although there is a very
interesting
variation I think I'll start with Bishop
F4 now white has to choose where to put
the
king
King E1 would lose a bishop imagine
we'll see either King D1 or King
C3 and the interesting variation I was
looking at was if King D1 I was thinking
about castling sack my bishop and then
win something back with a triple fork
with a rook um that's not quite
Happening Here and Now our Bishops are
having a staring contest my Bishop's not
defended so I probably have to
take there is a move Knight E7 which is
kind of clever allowing Bishop takes
bishop and then I have the fork on D5
and then win the bishop
back I could also Retreat this way but
feel like that would be a loss of
time yeah let's go ahead and take
because then The Rook is going to have
to take and I can
continue completing development like as
we head into the end
game ooh opponent throws in the
check what we call an in between move or
Z and Zug not recapturing right away uh
I think this only helps me though
because after
97 I basically get in this move for free
and White's going to have to win back
the
piece so that was a nice free Tempo I
could start with my
D5 I think I'd rather Castle
first just apply pressure to the
pawn and I'm giving white the chance to
play Knight D2 after which then Knight
D5 would force the king to B3 king would
not be able to retreat there and
meanwhile if King D2 right away
preparing Knight C3 then I can take the
pawn with
check so it's a little bit awkward for
white to develop like the king is very
awkward on C3 usually it's a pawn that
likes to be on C3 creating the pawn
chain got my apple cider is the season
of of apple cider happy
Autumn so yeah I'm curious what White's
going to do here it feels like a lot of
moves
are are losing something like any king
move would lose upon
Pawn okay we see Rook
E1 I could start with Knight D5 but
Knight D5 King D2 and then I can't win
the
pawn
so I'm going to keep my knight here I'm
going to play Rook to
E8 being very patient trying to optimize
everything else before I I pounce with
Knight D5
and this Rook is undefended on E1 so
Knight D5 attacks the king and the rook
and king D2 would
defend but yeah maybe I'm setting up
some forcing
combination okay we see Knight
A3 which is not a move I was expecting
this Knight doesn't seem to have a great
future this is what we call Superfluous
Knights where the knights defend each
other and in this case
they're a little bit awkward
cuz yeah this Knight doesn't really have
any good squares so B5 comes to mind as
a way
to push white back maybe set up B4 in
some
cases if I play B5 Knight
E3 not sure if I'm achieving much then
the Knight would hit the
bishop
another idea is to throw in the check
and then play Knight F4 which would
attack the D pawn and the g
Pawn I think I like that a bit
better Knight
D5 King B3 okay was not expecting
that
now and there's a really funny idea that
comes to
mind it's to
play
B5 and then if Knight E3 I I can play A5
threatening A4
checkmates white throws in this move and
here it's important to note I don't have
to recapture right away I can take the
Knight with
check and this wins a piece another
example of an in between move or a Zan
Zug however you pronounce it I'm sure
there's Germans watching that uh might
criticize my pronunciation there but
okay got the in between move one
material White's
King
is is being
feisty like both games so far my kings
are are uh being very
adventurous I mean white is threatening
to take the
[Music]
pawn but do I mind I'm look looking for
ways to set up some like mating
net I'll start with King D7 and just
defend yeah feels very close to
Checkmate especially after C4 like the
King has no legal moves
now and if we imagine my knight can get
to
D3 that would be checkmates
so okay so I'm threatening Maiden
one opponent saw I was also threatening
the pawn but
okay uh I didn't even realize I was
attacking
G2 so funny
finish
um it's funny in the previous episode of
the
speedrun almost all my opponents were
bringing out their Queen early but this
episode my opponents are bringing out
the king
early and I think that was pretty smooth
overall I did want to show just in the
opening uh usually in exchange variation
yeah white should not take the pawn
either castling or D4 I think they are
the two main
moves but after this it's known to be
good for white or for for black I should
say uh because white loses time having
to deal with these things I think most
players play 9 of3 allowing this and
this would go into a similar position to
what we got in the
game um and then yeah what my opponent
played was uh was interesting I thought
King D1 would be an interesting try to
really exploit my e file uh my plan was
if white went for this I was going to
play Bishop to E6 preparing to Castle
defending the pawn I think this should
be okay like even if Rook
E1 uh probably Queen digs
G2 maybe Queen D5 to be safe to pin the
Knight so yeah going back to what
happened in the game
I think all of this was uh was nice and
then yeah I didn't do anything too
special I just got my pieces to nice
centralized squares White's pieces got
awkward and then yeah this was um this
is a moment I I won material um I didn't
want to show if my opponent played
Knight E3 I was going to play I was
thinking about playing A5 and saying oh
no my bishop and then Checkmate and this
is a funny mating
idea so anyway fun game hopefully some
lessons to take
away uh let's do one
more playing dud
70 this might be the highest rated
opponent I've played th far don't think
I've played anyone over the rating of
800 okay we see Bishop C4 uh this is
called The Bishop's opening I'm going to
play Knight to C6 I wonder if we're
going to see attempted yeah we too
attempted Scholars mate so in the
previous episode we saw a few games with
early Queen H5 uh in this case yeah it's
just a matter of not getting mated block
the early attack and now G4 I've seen
this before uh this is a very aggressive
way of just trying to win the game very
quickly white wants to play this force
my knight to move and then still
Checkmate on
F7 so there are a few ways to deal with
this
um if I want to be super safe I could
play Queen E7 just to make sure the
Pawn's defended even a move like H6 to
prevent against
G5 um but here because White's not
threatening anything
immediately I have the move Knight to D4
and this is the beginning of my my
counterplay not only hitting the queen
but also hitting the pawn on
C2 and
yeah
white white doesn't have too many
options to defend the queen and the pawn
but this is one of
them and with this
move yeah again in the previous episode
I showed a tactic where I played Bishop
B4 provoke the queen to take and then
fork in this case if I play Bishop B4
it's not forcing like white doesn't have
to take and white could play Queen D3
and keep everything defended
I think if Bishop B4 Queen D3 then white
might be doing okay because C3 is not a
threat to Fork my
pieces so I think I'm much better off
probably just taking the
pawn it's a free Center Pawn could also
take the G
[Music]
Pawn um kind of spoiled for Choice here
I'll take the E4
pawn and yeah I'm attacking the queen
again I'm also setting up Pawn
D5 so if like moves a queen like to D3
which I think is the only safe Square to
keep C2 defended I can then play D5
defending and
attacking yeah we can see how quickly
such an opening can backfire like white
was trying to win in four moves uh but
now position is very very
grim and with D5 I'm also unleashing my
Bishop to attack the undefended pawn on
G4 here yeah very simply
C6 I could have taken but then Queen
takes I'd rather keep my knight in the
center and yeah I think here Bishop
takes G4 looks
nice and this is a situation there's a
lot of nice looking moves like B5 Bishop
C5 uh with Bishop G4 I should
acknowledge that white has a move F3 to
Fork but the drawback of F3 is exposes a
king and allows Queen H4 check so I
wouldn't mind if white plays this
move and the goal going forward is is
probably still to go for Queen
H4 have to give white the taste of their
own
medicine um now it's
uh very Justified bringing out the queen
to try and finish off the
game
um I think the simplest approach is n
left to this is a triple Fork I think
some people call this Royal
Fork White has one legal move move the
king back to the starting square and
then I'll take the queen with double
check the Knight and my queen will be
delivering check uh we might see
resignation
here we might see uh Checkmate next move
King F1 Queen F2
checkmates and if King D1 then Queen E1
checkmates okay yeah definitely no mercy
La ging uh another example of how to
punish someone who's trying to to win
quickly um I know a lot of players do
crumble against this G4 idea especially
at the the lower levels but it's really
nothing to be scared of and against
opponents who go for for this uh you
should just look for ways to make sure
everything's defended first of all but
then look for ways to get an attack of
your
own so um let's do one more with every
episode I post people are asking for
longer
episodes so I think we're at game number
four for this one play another King's
Pawn and here we have a more normal
opening we might see another Spanish
have an
Italian uh I'll play Bishop
C5 with Bishop C5 I'm avoiding any like
Knight G5 ideas um yeah because the
queen would still control
G5 and with D3 uh this is very standard
italion here I'm happy to play Knight
of6 and just prepare to
Castle if white goes for Knight G5 in
this case I don't mind castling I think
it was what episode three maybe episode
2 or three where we saw my opponents uh
basically go for this trade on
F7 which it looks scary like if takes
takes takes takes I lose a rook and a
pawn my king gets a bit more
exposed uh but that variation is
actually very good for black
because the two minor pieces are much
more valuable than rook and Pawn so my
opponent's not going for the media trade
um I could play H6 and kick the Knight
away maybe provoke it to trade I think
I'd rather just play
D6 just open up my
bishop and might have some options here
uh we might see castling we might see
the bishop
develop Bishop E3 okay so
challenging my
Bishop there's a few ways to deal with
this uh for one I of course could take
which like the more I'm looking at the
more I like
it there's other moves too there's
H6 there
is uh there's like Bishop B6 if I want
to just drop back and be solid but I'm
looking at the idea of
taking and then after white
takes I have the move Knight
G4 which seems a little little bit over
ambitious but I do attack the Knight and
the pawn both of which are
undefended in that variation I think
I'll go for
it trying to take advantage of the fact
that white I mean white has multiple
targets my king is castled White's king
is not
castled and I'm essentially trying to
seize initiative before white can
complete
development um now when I took on E3
after this trade the file becomes half
open for
whites so I just have to be extra
careful of ideas of like Rook F1 and
queen F3 uh but those moves didn't
really work and this move doesn't really
work either because the Knight is just
hanging um I probably don't want to take
on
E3 even though taking on E3 would be a
triple
Fork um whenever you consider a move
like this you have to ask yourself what
does opponent want to do in response and
then I think Queen H5 would be very
difficult to deal with in that case so
let's take the
Knight my opponent just um just didn't
realize the Knight was
attacked and the nice thing here is I
have two attackers against E3 there's no
Defenders so I'm pretty much guaranteed
to win this Pawn next move I really
don't see how white can save
it and there's a move D5 to
Counterattack but even then I can take
with check or take and attack the
queen okay white has triple isolated e
pawns and now it's a choice uh do I take
the E3 Pawn with the queen with the
Knight I can also take on E5 with this
Knight I really feel spoiled for
choice I think I'll take on E3 with the
Knight hitting the queen I mean there's
so many
targets next move I can take if I want I
can also maybe look to take on G2 with
check and just go straight for the
attack against White's
King expecting the queen to move and the
queen
has E2 and D3
to defend the bishop doesn't say if if
Queen D3 Knight takes E5 would be a fork
but
here yeah Queen E2 I think I might as
well just take with
check and white is most likely not going
to be castling this
game unless white wants to sack the
queen and then Castle but wouldn't mind
there so probably we'll see King F2 or
King
F1 the drawback of King F1 is then I
have another check I also have Bishop H3
in in some
cases get another piece
involved I mean with the white king so
exposed like this the strategy is to try
and get more pieces into play like my
knight and queen are doing a nice job
but it would be very nice to get
especially my minor pieces on the queen
side towards the king's
side so yeah I like this move Bishop
H3 just aligning with the King defending
the Knight setting up discoveries
uh I am threatening Knight to F4 check
to attack the king and the queen I feel
like I'm also close to creating some
sort of mating
that okay King
F2 yeah feels very close to mating
somehow like Queen F4 Queen
H4 I think in both those cases the king
is going to try and hide on
G1
so I'm just going to take on E5
first and I'm keeping these options open
I'm also creating the option of Knight
G4
check and with two knights the bishop
and the queen like all swarming
around reminds me of one of those uh
movie scenes where you're you're stuck
in the ocean and the sharks are are
ready to have a nice
meal okay so
Knight wait Knight
G4 it's important in this position to
just
consider the various options cuz there's
also Queen F4 or queen H4 and there's no
more King
G1 so actually
I I think Queen F4 and queen H4 are both
made in two I'll play Queen
H4 so I think the more static made into
White's only legal move is King
F1 and then Knight E3 will be double
check and
mate a knight and Bishop attack the king
there's no way to block or
capture so that was a pleasant
finish uh another case where my
opponent in some sense disobeyed some
opening
principles uh didn't really see this
threat but even even if white saw like
both threats
here I think it's already tricky for
white to deal with
it of course white should save the
Knight maybe here the best option is to
trade on on
F7 uh because if Knight F3 I'm happy to
take and then win a clean Pawn trade on
C4
so anyway another fun hopefully
instructive game hope you guys enjoyed
this episode if you have questions or
comments leave them below if you like
the content hit subscribe like it does
help the channel grow and I'll see you
guys in the next episode stay tuned